Is there a time that you no longer load questions for zoom calls?
Is there a way to tell if a question that was submitted was uploaded by you?
Well, if you ask the question on the site, and I don't have an answer that you know you didn't get on here.
So I asked that you try to get your questions in, you know, half hour before the zoom call.
That's just my request for you.
But this question came in two minutes before the zoom call.
So I just saw it and put it out here.
So yes, I'll try to get questions in as best I possibly can up to, you know, right when we do the zoom call.
But sometimes that's not possible.
So if you ask a question and it doesn't get on here, it just you try to get it in a little earlier next time.
So they let it get on here.
It'll be on the next one.
So if I didn't put your question on the zoom call, it will be on the next zoom call unless it's a question that you've asked multiple times.
We've had that happen where a person has asked the exact same question multiple times that they didn't look at them.
I answered it at last zoom call and they asked it again, you know, and because they didn't listen to the last zoom call.
They weren't able to get on, but they didn't listen to it.
So I didn't necessarily put that on again because all the people that have jumped on and listened to it or regular people are, they'd be like, you answer that.
I think you answered this last week.
So I don't do that if it's a duplicate question.
But if you ask a question, if you posted a question and it didn't get on that week, zoom call, it would be on the next week.